president trump still has all the powers
of the presidency but this
is as you as we've been telling you his
last full day in office
ben tracy is at the white house with
more on that part of the story
ben what do we expect from the president
today
gail good morning two words for today
pardons and commutation
sources here at the white house tell us
that president trump could issue up to
100 of them
now it's not entirely clear who will be
receiving them but mr trump's former
political aide steve bannon and personal
attorney rudy giuliani could be on the
list
so far president trump has actually used
his clemency powers
far less than president george w bush or
president obama
who the day before he left office
pardoned or commuted the sentences of
330 people mostly low-level drug
offenders with mandatory sentences
but unlike them president trump insists
he has the power to pardon
himself that would be a controversial
move in an admission of guilt
that could anger senate republicans who
are jurors in his impeachment trial
now we haven't seen president trump in
public in more than six days
and since he's been from twitter we've
barely heard from him
now president trump is going to be
skipping all of the inauguration events
he's going to head to florida
early wednesday morning after a farewell
event at joint base andrews
he will have the so-called nuclear
football that's the briefcase that
includes the nuclear codes with him
until noon tomorrow a separate briefcase
will be here in washington
ready for president biden once he's
sworn in
tony all right ben if the president
pardons himself i think a lot of people
will be saying pardon my french
thank you very much